[Music]  hey everybody its Becca Tilly here and I  am reading the most dramatic tweets ever  tweeted to me just another day waking up  why I'm not wondering why I'm not Becca  Tilly yet me being drunk off only three  drinks maybe B maybe why I'm crying but  it's also because Becca Tilly likes to  come  he's probably the three drinks okay why  are ja Fletcher and Becca Tilly so  pretty  Oh The Bachelor will never see another  girl like Becca Tilly  that is so nice I've never seen these  does anyone else think Becca Tilly's  voice is annoying AF still gorgeous I  understand that I hate like the thought  of watching this back is already  stressing me out having to listen to  myself so imagine having a podcast but  thank you for singing pretty actually  crying real tears because I can't meet  Becca Tilly today there's always next  time  Peyton if Becca Tilly can't find love we  are all doomed that's a lot of pressure  [Music]  [Applause]